السكان والضيوف الأعزاء
سان بطرسبرج
اليوم هو يوم البحرية
تشعر روسيا أن الناس بطولية
مهن المدافعين عن الوطن
المحاربين الذين ربطوا مصائرهم بالخدمة
على البحر
عاش الأسطول الروسي الذي أنشأه في
المعارك والمعارك هي واحدة من
رموز الشخصية الوطنية
التاريخ
هذا التاريخ ليس فقط البحرية ولكن أيضا
مجد الدولة للوطن
يبدأ هذا التاريخ بشجاعة
البحارة الروس الذين ربحوا الجانج
معركة احتيال
في جميع الأوقات البحارة بشرف و
دافعت الكرامة عن مصالح روسيا
فازت بانتصارات رائعة
العدو
في ذكرى الشعب الممتنة أبدًا
سوف يتلاشى مجد مآثر الروس
أسطول بالقرب من التندرا الصادقة في كورفو وسينوب
مساهمة كبيرة في اقتراب النصر في
الحرب الوطنية العظمى
البحرية التي شاركت
في كل الدفاعية والهجومية
عمليات
الشجاعة والبطولة الأسطورية للبحر
جنود المشاة
الشجاعة والتضحية الشخصية
تكوين الطيران البحري الساحلي
أطقم مدفعية الغواصات و
السفن السطحية
مآثر عمال بناء السفن و
صناعة إصلاح السفن إلى الأبد
ستبقى في ذاكرة الأحفاد بالامتنان
اليوم استعادة التاريخية
تقاليد الأسطول الروسي لأول مرة في
أحدث تاريخ لروسيا
رئيس الاتحاد الروسي
العرض البحري الرئيسي سيقام
لأول مرة في تاريخ البحرية
المسيرات في سانت بطرسبرغ
سيشارك في العرض في نفس الوقت
بحارة بحر البلطيق والبحر الأسود
أساطيل شمال المحيط الهادئ و
أسطول بحر قزوين
العدد الإجمالي للأفراد
المشاركة في العرض
موكب أكثر من خمسة آلاف شخص
90 غواصة تشارك
قوارب الطائرات والمروحيات
القوات البحرية
حاليا القائد العام
أميرال البحرية فلاديمير
وصل كوروليف إلى مدفأة دون بيير
قلعة بطرس وبولس حيث في الوضع
مؤتمرات الفيديو سوف تأخذ التقارير
قادة الأسطول على جاهزية القوات
القوات البحرية لإجراء
العرض البحري الرئيسي
[موسيقى]
الرفيق القائد الأعلى
قوات وقوات البحرية في
عقد في الرئيسي
العرض البحري جاهز
القائد العام للقوات البحرية
الأدميرال كوروليف
[موسيقى]
الانتباه يتحدث ويظهر
سان بطرسبرج
استدعاء اليوم الجديد للبحرية
رئيس البحرية الروسية الأسطول
موكب
طلقة تحية لمدفع بيتروبافلوفسك
أعطت القلعة إشارة البدء
احتفالات يوم البحرية
روسيا
[موسيقى]
القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحة
من قبل قوات الاتحاد الروسي
وزير الدفاع في الاتحاد الروسي و
القائد العام للقوات البحرية
بداية حركة العرض سيرتب السفن
تقع على طرق بتروبافلوفسك
القلاع
[موسيقى]
القارب يقترب من هبوط كبير
سفينة مينسك
قائد سفينة نقيب من الرتبة الثالثة
أنطون نيكولين سفن إنزال كبيرة
مشروع 775 هي القوى الرئيسية
الهبوط البرمائي
ساحل نقل غير مجهز
القوات والمركبات المدرعة
خلال العمليات البحرية ، طاقم كبير
تلقت سفينة الإنزال مينسك
المشاركة في عملية مكافحة الإرهاب
الجمهورية العربية السورية
[موسيقى]
مرحبا الرفاق
نشرب
القوات البحرية
[موسيقى]
خط العرض
طاقم سفينة صغيرة مضادة للغواصات
يورنجوي
في قيادة السفينة ملازم أول
كونستانتين كوزلوف
[موسيقى]
في عام 2017 كجزء من مجموعة تكتيكية
طاقم السفن المضادة للغواصات
انتصر على شفاه القائد العام
القوات البحرية
عداد تحت الماء يبرد و
[تصفيق]
القوات البحرية
على طريق الرئيس الروسي
الاتحادات
حراس القارب الصاروخي ديميتروفغراد
الذي يمثل فقط
سفينة حرس أسطول البلطيق
مجمع
قائد سفينة نقيب من الرتبة الثالثة
دميترينكو له
[موسيقى]
كراسنوفا ورفاقه
العلم البحري على
[موسيقى]
أسلحة صاروخية قوية و
سرعة السفينة العالية
السماح له بأن يكون جزءًا من مجموعات السفن
وتوجيه ضربات صاروخية على السطح
سفن وسفن العدو للسفينة
شارك في 30 حملة من حملات السفن
أسطول البلطيق
أكمل العشرات من التدريبات القتالية
باستخدام المدفعية البحرية
الحرب الإلكترونية و
محمول
ليس على أنظمة الصواريخ
[موسيقى]
لكن
الأسطول الروسي
في جميع الأوقات تكريم مقدس البحر
التقاليد ، الكثير منها لها تأثيرها
ابتداء من العصر البطرسي
واحدة من أقدم وأكثرها احتراما
التقاليد الجسدية
موكب بحري في مختلف
فترات تاريخية
وجهات النظر حول إقامة المسيرات البحرية
خضعت لتغييرات كبيرة
حدثت تحولات كبرى في
أعاد المجتمع النظر في وجهات النظر حول
تطبيق البحرية
تحسين تكوينه ولكن جوهره
ظل العرض كما هو منذ بتروفسكي
مرات حتى يومنا هذا
موكب السفن من أهم المناظر
طقوس عسكرية للبحرية
يحدث في أيام
الأعياد والاحتفالات الرسمية
الدولة والأهمية العسكرية أ
أيضًا بعد تمارين أو مناورات كبيرة
في السنوات الأخيرة ، أصبح موكب السفن
المكون الرئيسي للاحتفال باليوم
البحرية الروسية العقل
الاجتماع على يمين قارب الرئيس
الاتحاد الروسي
تقترب من الخط الأمامي للسفن
يقع في الجامعة
الجسر
خط العرض الأول في سانت بطرسبرغ
كورفيت أوامر السفينة عنيد
كابتن الرتبة الثالثة أنطون جانين
[موسيقى]
نحت
ينتمي إلى فئة السفن متعددة الأغراض
المنطقة البحرية
على متن السفينة أنظمة التحكم
أسلحة الصواريخ
يديرونها متعدد الوظائف
المدفعية وطوربيد الألغام
التسلح
[موسيقى]
قارب رئيس الاتحاد الروسي
تقترب من ترتيب الجيل الجديد
الأدميرال ماكاروف
قائد سفينة نقيب رتبة ثانية
صلاة غريغوري
[موسيقى]
الأدميرال ماكاروف
3 من سلسلة السفن ذاتية البناء
بناء مصنع العنبر و
لأسطول البحر الأسود الألوية الأولى
الأدميرال جريجوروفيتش الأدميرال إيسين بالفعل
انضم إلى الأسطول بنجاح
شارك في العملية العسكرية في سوريا
الجمهورية العربية
يكمل موكب السفن
غواصة كبيرة تعمل بالديزل والكهرباء
قارب dmitrov يقود قبطان السفينة
المرتبة الثانية سيرجي أولينيكوف
أنت تعطي البحرية غواصة
مشروع قارب 877
هي واحدة من أصغر الإطارات
غواصات
سفينة العالم المصممة للخارج
لنا السفن والغواصات
غمرها في الصباح
بنيت في حوض بناء السفن
أحمر مع
في عام 2014 ، تمت ترقيته إلى
سفينة مصنع كرونشتاد البحري
مجهزة بطوربيد منجم حديث
هل ستكون قادرًا على القيام به
ومهام مثل
كالتالي
أثناء خدمة الغواصة
شارك ضد
اليوم
الطاقم والسفينة
جيلي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رئيس الاتحاد الروسي
السفن الالتفافية واقفة على 3 وما فوق
نسخ أو لقطات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لكن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
منذ عام 1936 بمبادرة
مفوض الشعب في البحرية
سريع
نيكولاي جيراسيموفيتش كوزنتسوف
بدأت المسيرات البحرية تقام
في البلاد على أساس منتظم في أيام
العطلات الرسمية
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قارب الرئيس الروسي
الاتحادات
ابتهج يوم الاميرال
و الجسر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
علم سانت جورج من البارجة أزوج
في فترة ما بعد الظهر من الاجتماع على حق natra
و
إلى ميدان مجلس الشيوخ
الآثار التاريخية للأسطول الروسي
خطة ستيرن سانت جورج الخطية
سفينة
الأساسيات
قيادة السفينة من الخط
كابتن 1st رتبة لازاريف
فازت بانتصار رائع على خمسة
سفن العدو في نافارينو
المعركة كما كتب عن الفريق الثالث على الإطلاق
اسم بطارية بندقية
بدا كل شيء
من استدار أمامنا لم يكن هناك مكان
حيث لم تتحقق من قلب الحلمات الحقيقي و
وقتل رصاصة خلال المعركة على آزوف
كل الصواري والأسلوب
بدن به 153 ثقبا
لكنه خرج من معركة غير متكافئة
كان الفائزون عندي مميزين بشكل خاص
الملازم وبافل ناخيموف
إيفان بي يانيف ضابط البحرية فلاديمير كورنيلوف
سوف يمر ضابط البحرية فلاديمير استومين
القليل من الوقت والفترة نسبيًا
أمير حرب القرم ناخيموف كورنيلوف
وسوف يقود استومين الدفاع البطولي
يشار إلى سيفاستوبول من قبل الإمبراطور صاحب السيادة
نيكولاس الأول في 17 ديسمبر 1827
لأول مرة في تاريخ الأسطول الروسي
تم منح Azog إلى البارجة
صارم
بركات الأدميرال جورجيفسك وتكريمه
سيعطي أفعال الحماية للزعماء
شجاعة الضباط وشجاعتهم
شجاعة
الرتب الدنيا من لوحة المؤخرة سانت جورج
أصبح رمزا للشجاعة والبطولة و
المرونة
البحارة الروس هذا العام سنفعل
احتفلوا بالذكرى الـ 190 لميلاد نوفوسيلسكي
المعارك
وحدة حرس الشرف
تقترب من البرج الرئيسي
الأميرالية
اليوم ولأول مرة في تاريخ روسيا
سريع
علم المؤخرة سانت جورج الخطي
سيتم رفع سفينة آزوف أعلاه
بطرسبرج في ذكرى الاستحقاق
البحارة الروس
مع حماية المصالح الوطنية لنا
الوطن
[موسيقى]
أنت
رئيس الاتحاد الروسي
القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحة
من قبل قوات الاتحاد الروسي فلاديمير
فلاديميروفيتش بوتين
الرفاق البحارة و الملاحقون سيف الذنب و
الضباط والأدميرالات
قدامى المحاربين الأعزاء
أهنئكم في يوم البحرية
سريع
يتم الاحتفال بهذا العيد في كل منطقة
روسيا وبطبيعة الحال مع خاص
الاحتفاء في القواعد وفي الحاميات
شمال المحيط الهادئ
أساطيل بحر البلطيق والبحر الأسود
أسطول بحر قزوين تاريخ روسيا
ترتبط ارتباطًا وثيقًا بالانتصارات و
شجاع شجاعة
مكانة عالية البحرية
كانت دولة كقوة بحرية قوية
غزا
شجاعة البحارة وضباط المواهب
شركات بناء السفن جريئة البحث
رواد على مر القرون
شجاعة وصمود البحارة الروس
اشتدت في المعارك في البحر والبر
شحذ مهاراتهم العسكرية
عزز تقاليد الفريد
الأخوة البحرية في سنوات العظماء
وقف الجنين المنزلي حتى الموت
شواطئ وحدود الوطن الأم إلى الأبد
حوليات الانتصار العظيم في معركة أوديسا
وسيفاستوبول مآثر سيفيرومورز
المرحلات الأسطورية للغواصات السوفيتية
الدفاع عن لينينغراد ومنيع
أسطول كرونشتاد والتفاني في خدمة الوطن
لا ينفصلان كما قال الأدميرال ناخيموف
لا توجد طريقة صعبة أو سهلة للبحار
لا يوجد سوى واحد مجيد واليوم هذا
جميع الذين يخدمون في العهد مؤمنون
القوات السطحية والغواصات
القوات الساحلية للطيران الذين يعملون فيها
سفن صناعة البناء عالية
الصفات الأخلاقية والمهنية
كانت ولا تزال أساس خدمة ناجحة
في الأسطول وسيتم تعزيزهم
الدعم الكامل للدولة اليوم
يتم عمل الكثير لتطوير و
ترقيات بناء البحرية
دخول السفن الحديثة
تحسين نظام القتال
تدريب أفراد البحرية
هذا هو اختيار الأشخاص الأقوياء وذوي الإرادة القوية
قادرة على تحدي عناصر أولئك الذين
لا يتخيل نفسه بدون بحر بدون صعوبة و
خدمة نبيلة للوطن احترامها
أصدقاء البحرية اليوم
لا يحل فقط التقليدية بالنسبة له
مهام
ولكنها تستحق أيضًا الاستجابة للتحديات الجديدة
يقدم مساهمة كبيرة في الكفاح ضد
القرصنة الإرهابية بواسطة البحارة
البحرية الحديثة
الأطفال والأحفاد سيفخرون بهم
هذا بسبب إتقانها المتميز
أكد الانضباط الفوري
في كل من التدريبات والعمليات القتالية
شكرا لكل من ينتظرك في العائلة
الموقد يدفئك بالحب شكرا لك
لك لاستعدادك وقدرتك على حل أكثر
مهام صعبة لخدمة جديرة بالتقدير و
ولاء لا يتزعزع لوطننا الأم
اشخاص
كلمات للبحرية عطلة سعيدة
يا هلا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يوم البحرية في روسيا
أصبحت عالمية حقًا
والاحتفال المفضل بالعطلة قادم
عبر بلادنا من شواطئ المحيط الهادئ
إلى بحر البلطيق الرمادي من القطب الشمالي القاسي إلى
البحر الاسود
ولكن لا تزال الاحتفالات الرئيسية ستقام
هنا هي العاصمة البحرية لروسيا على نهر نيفا
أسوار الأميرالية الرئيسية للبلاد وفي
استعادة كرونشتاد اليوم
التقاليد التاريخية للأسطول الروسي
لأول مرة في تاريخ روسيا الحديث
قرار رئيس الاتحاد الروسي
العرض البحري الرئيسي يقام
المسيرة تجري في وقت واحد للجميع
أساطيل العام البحري
تنجذب أيضا المشاركة في العرض
السفن في الخدمة القتالية
الجزء الشرقي
[موسيقى]
أول مسيرة حقيقية
الناس لا ينبغي اعتبار 7 فصول عرضا
9 سبتمبر ألف وسبعمائة
تكريما لانتصار البحارة الروس على التوالي و
أيضا
هكذا الحال
فوقنا ايضا لان هذا الانتصار
كان 1
أسطول روسي طويل بجودة عالية
وتجمع المتفرجون في القارب على
ضفاف الرصيف
تزلج ولكن جلبت أيضا
السويدية مع أطقم 2 و goblin جزئياً
ابتهاج الناس بحماس
الفائزين من الأميرالية و
قلعة بطرسبورغ 3 قطع وحيى
من كل البنادق
مواكب لسفن الأسطول الروسي
فشل من قبل الرهبان الآخرين
لذلك تحت حكم كاثرين الثانية
سبعمائة وستة وتسعون سنة في هذه المناسبة
إرسال سرب من الأدميرال سبيريدوف
البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​للحرب مع تركيا
أقيم عرض بحري في العهد
الإسكندر الأول
تم إجراء أعلى مراجعة للسرب
الأدميرال سينيافين على نطاق واسع
كان موكب سفن الأسطول الروسي
نفذها الإمبراطور نيكولاس الأول 3
يوليو 1836 في مثل هذا اليوم
تم اصطفاف أسطول البلطيق في ثلاثة خطوط
في غارة كرونشتاد
يبدأ الجزء البحري من العرض
افتح ممر الخط الأمامي
السفن
قوارب مكافحة التخريب
علم الدولة الروسية
علم الاتحاد من وزارة الدفاع
الاتحاد الروسي والبحرية
علم
هذا النوع من القوة البحرية ، قوة لها
موقع جغرافي
اكتشافات جغرافية عظيمة
النجاح في إتقان وتطوير الجديد
أراضي الانتصارات الرائعة للروس
أسطول التميز
العلوم المحلية والصناعة في
بناء السفن تحت الماء والسطحية
مثل أي قوة عظمى ، روسيا لديها
مصالحهم الخاصة في المحيطات
وجود السفن تحت الدولة
علم الاتحاد الروسي من بعيد
البحرية ل
يحمي مصالحنا
بلد
مناطق مهمة استراتيجيًا في العالم
محيط
مكافحة التخريب في الخطوط الأمامية
قارب الجندي الشاب حكايات
سمي على اسم الوطني الجديد
حركة الشباب الحديثة
مصمم لإحياء أفضل التقاليد
المدافعين عن الأرض الروسية
اليوم ، سوف يسير جندي شاب في تشكيل استعراضي
ينام الآن القطب الشمالي
كامتشاتكا بريموري وشبه جزيرة القرم
قائد مجموعة من كبار ضابط القوارب
الكسندر كوسينسكي لمكافحة التخريب
قوارب المشروع 21980 هريرة
مصممة للقتال
التخريب والقوى الارهابية في
مناطق المياه من النقاط الأساسية والقريبة
النهج لهم وكذلك لتقديمها
المساعدة لدائرة الحدود
في حماية الدولة البحرية
حدود القوارب الروسية من هذا النوع
أداء المهام لضمان
أمن الألعاب الأولمبية الشتوية
سوتشي
المنتديات الاقتصادية سانت بطرسبرغ
[موسيقى]
على طول جسر Admiralteyskaya
مركبة الإنزال مع fotik لبطرس الأكبر
جد
لقاء الأسطول الروسي الأول مع القوطيين في
السفن الحربية لأسطول البلطيق
وقع في 11 أغسطس 1723 في اليوم السابق
الذكرى الثانية لسلام نيشتات
ضع نهايه ل
الحرب الشمالية الدائمة و
أعلن للعالم عن انسحاب روسيا
البحر تكريما لهذا الحدث السفن
اصطف في كرونشتاد
غارة
اليوم التقليد الذي وضعه بطرس
إحياء عظيم البحرية
أصبح صاروخًا نوويًا يسير في المحيط
وقادر على حماية الوطنية
مصالح الوطن في أي وقت
المحيطات
[موسيقى]
يتذكر البحارة التقاليد ويكرمونها مقدسًا
تاريخ الأسطول الروسي
أكثر من ثلاثمائة وعشرين عامًا
تمر دوريات الاستعراض
قوارب نوع رابتور مبنية عليها
مصنع لينينغراد لبناء السفن
غنى
هذه هي أسرع سفينة في التكوين
يمكن البحرية سرعتهم
تصل إلى 50 عقدة
إنها حوالي مائة كيلومتر في الساعة من السفن
مصممة لتقديم
أمن السفينة ولكن غير محمية
كشف الرف
اعتراض واحتجاز قليلا صالح للإبحار
أهداف لضمان الوحدات
الأغراض البحرية الخاصة
أداء أسطول البحث و
إنقاذ الناس في مناطق القتال
قائمة الواجب
القوارب تحمل رايات وأعلام المعركة
مشهورة في سنوات العظمة
اتصالات الحرب الوطنية
البحرية في الغارة أليس كذلك
راية المعركة للفأس المنخفض لأمر أوشاكوف
لواء من الصيادين من الدرجة الأولى
غواصات الأسطول الشمالي
[موسيقى]
يمر بزورق دورية في البحر الأسود
أسطول بعلم المعركة 1
ترتيب سيفاستوبول من ناخيموف أولا
درجات لواء زورق طوربيد
أسطول البحر الأسود خلال العظيم
حرب وطنية
شارك أفراد اللواء
هبوط كيرتش فيودوسيا
عمليات في معارك العمليات الروسية
من أجل تامان
الدول المحررة أوديسا وشبه جزيرة القرم
الشجاعة والبطولة
الآلاف من بحارة القوارب كانوا
منحت الطلبات والميداليات
زورق دورية من القرم
قاعدة بحرية
يحمل راية المعركة من وسام أوشاكوف الأول
لواء الصيد بشباك الجر من الدرجة الأولى
أميرالية أسطول البحر الأسود
جسر يقترب من دورية
القوارب
جندي شاب من بحر البلطيق والجندي الشاب من شبه جزيرة القرم مع
لافتات معركة من 1 و 2 شقق
فرق المراكب المدرعة لجيش الفولجا
أساطيل
الانقسام وقام بدور نشط في
الدفاع البطولي عن تمثيل ستالينجراد
على اتصالات المياه
دمرتها قذائف الهاون
القوى البشرية والمعدات المناسبة للعدو
عرض الشجاعة والبطولة
الأفراد عند إطلاق سراحهم
كان يوغوسلافيا الدرجة الأولى
اللقب الفخري
راية معركة بلغراد 1
راية حمراء لواء الصيد بشباك الجر
أسطول البلطيق مكلف بالحمل
لأفضل طاقم زورق دورية
قاعدة لينينغراد البحرية
أسطول البلطيق
جسر الأميرالية يقترب
ضد التخريب يشتعل قدير نورميك
راية المعركة لأمر الراية الحمراء
مثل لواء طوربيد من الدرجة الأولى
قوارب الأسطول الشمالي للشجاعة و
البطولة التي أظهرها الأفراد
الكتائب
أثناء تحرير المدينة ، فرن إنجا
حصل اللواء على لقب فخري
بيشيرسكايا
[موسيقى]
ساحة مجلس الشيوخ تلتقي بعلم المعركة
7 سخالين منفصلة
تقسيم راية حمراء من كاسحات ألغام
مآثر أسطول المحيط الهادئ للبحارة
المحيط الهادئ منقوشًا فيها إلى الأبد
تاريخ البحرية
[موسيقى]
يمارس الجنس مع قارب مكافحة التخريب
جزء من قوات الغواصة
يحمل الأسطول الشمالي بفخر
راية المعركة لأمر الراية الحمراء
أوشاكوف من الدرجة الأولى لواء الغواصة
قوارب الأسطول الشمالي خلال الحرب
لواء الغواصات النشطة
تصرفت على اتصالات العدو
عطل نقله العسكري
غطى الحلفاء بحر بارنتس
قوافل من ضربات أرض العدو
السفن والعمل كان مختلفا
الابتكار في تكتيكات جريئة و
هجمات جريئة
وحده
زورق مكافحة التخريب Nakhimovets
طاقم السفينة بنتائج عالية
تدريب قتالي خانق على الحق في الحمل
في العرض ، علم المعركة هو الأول
وسام الراية الحمراء لنخيموف أولا
درجات لواء زورق طوربيد
أسطول البلطيق سنوات لواء الحرب
شارك في الدفاع او لصالح و
فيلا تالين جزر إيمان دوما
القتال ضد العدو
ريغا مينسك نارفا وفيبورغ
خلجان خلال لواء القتال
أعطى 93 وأتلف 32
سفينة العدو لأغراض مختلفة
كل البحارة وضباط اللواء كانوا
رشح لجوائز الدولة
أحد عشر
حصل على لقب بطل الاتحاد السوفيتي
[موسيقى]
مثل عالم جسر التاي
قارب عليه علم معركة يقترب من 1
لواء طوربيد راية حمراء
القوارب
أسطول المحيط الهادئ لا تتلاشى كلمة
المدافعين عن الشرق الأقصى وبريموري
يلهم جيل الشباب من البحارة
يستحق أداء مهام التدريب القتالي
الأنشطة يساهم في
مستوى الاستعداد القتالي للأفراد
سريع
[موسيقى]
يكمل مرور زوج هذه المجموعة
هبوط الطائرات
القوارب من هذا النوع مخصصة ل
لهبوط المركبات القتالية المتعقبة
سلاح مشاة البحرية غير مجهز
ساحل
بسبب ميزات التصميم
يمكن أن تصل سرعة القارب إلى ثلاثين
ست عقد على متن القارب
ناقلة جند مدرعة BTR-80 2 رئيسية
قائد مركبات مشاة البحرية القتالية
قوارب كبار الضباط مكسيم بانينكا
الجد الأكبر مكسيم عادي الغجر نيكولاي
ستيبانوفيتش
في مارس 1943 توفي في معارك المدينة
فييازما
[موسيقى]
المصعد الذي نبنيه
مداهمة وقاعدة كاسحات ألغام
لواء اللواء الأحمر الشهير
سفن حماية المنطقة المائية
قاعدة لينينغراد البحرية الروسية
هي مسقط رأس ليس فقط لي
الأسلحة ولكن أيضا كاسحات الألغام خلال العظيمة
من الحرب الوطنية الأولى
سفن حراسة بحرية
أصبح الأسطول كاسحة ألغام t-205
يسقط العديد من البحارة والملاحظين و
تم منح ضباط كاسحة ألغام
جوائز الدولة العالية ل
أداء الأعمال المتعلقة بالألغام
كاسحات ألغام مجهزة بأعماق البحار
الاتصال الكهرومغناطيسي و
شباك الجر الصوتية لحل المشاكل
الدفاع عن النفس عليها مثبتة و
30 ملم مدفعية
التسلح الفعلي لهذه السفن
يسمح بوسائل السفينة
اكتشف جميع أنواع الأميال البحرية على
أعماق مختلفة
كاسحات ألغام من المشاريع المقدمة
نفذت العمليات بنجاح
إزالة الألغام من قناة السويس
والخليج الفارسي في 2009 2010
القوى الحقيقية نصف ساعة
سنوات ومهام
إزالة الألغام
مياه خليج فنلندا وبحر البلطيق
البحار
خلال بناء خط الغاز الشمالي
تدفق
تم ابطال مفعول اكثر من 60 متفجرات
العناصر الشفوية 2011
نفذ الأسطول الشمالي المهام ل
إزالة الألغام في خليج أوب والساحل
أجزاء من بحر كارا
[موسيقى]
موكب تشكيل كاسحة ألغام بحرية جديدة
جيل الكسندر Obukhov
صمم من قبل البحرية المركزية
مكتب التصميم
أوامر الماس قبطان السفينة
المرتبة الثالثة سيرجي تيخونوف
[موسيقى]
تفتح سفينة الدفاع عن الألغام
صفحة جديدة في تطوير المناجم
القوات الطبيعية للبحرية
السفينة ليس لها نظائرها في
ميزات التصميم و
الخصائص التكتيكية والفنية
مصممة للبحث والتدمير
الألغام في مياه القواعد البحرية
مسافة آمنة للسفينة
لديها
فريد من نوعه
جسم مصنوع من الألياف الزجاجية متجانسة
شكلت
هناك فراغ تجدهم دعونا
يجب أن يصبح المشروع منصة طور
لإنشاء سفن مضادة للألغام
الدفاع في أطقم المنطقة البحرية القريبة
يتم تحسين كاسحات الألغام يوميًا
التدريب والاحتراف البحري في
السنة الحالية
أكثر من
20 تمرين من مختلف الأنواع وأكثر من 200 تمرين
تدريبات قتالية
[موسيقى]
في عام 1699
تم تحديد علم القديس أندراوس من قبل بيتر
أولاً كرمز رسمي
كلود الروسية
أول ميثاق سفينة في روسيا
ورنيش مدبب أبيض عبر
هذا لديه صليب سانت أندرو الأزرق
OEM المعمد روسيا
سفينة تدخل ممر نيفا
مجموعة الصدمة من المشاهير
وسام الراية الحمراء لنخيموف أولا
درجة لواء سفن الصواريخ و
القوارب
من أسطول البلطيق هذا العام
احتفلوا رسميًا بالذكرى المجيدة لتسعين
سنوات من تاريخ التكوين
يرأس تشكيل الصاروخ الاحتفالي
مشروع قارب Chuvash 1241 الطابق لا
من فرقة الحرس الاول
قوارب الصواريخ
بأمر من قائد الثالث
رتبة أرتيوم ستاركوف
من المفترض أن تدمر السفينة
السفن الحربية
مركبات النقل والهبوط
تعزيزات الدفاع الجوي للعدو
الدفاع عن جثة السفن من الطيران المنخفض
وسائل الهجوم التي تغطي هذه الجماعات
من هجمات قوات العدو الخفيفة
روسيا رائدة
مساحات بناء زوارق الصواريخ صغيرة
أبعاد السكن عالية السرعة
القدرة على المناورة والتأثير
جعلت أسلحة الصواريخ كبيرة
تعديلات على تكتيكات القوات البحرية
في هذه السفن الصغيرة متناقضة
طريقة الجمع بين القليل والنزوح
وقوة تثقيب كبيرة
تكلفة منخفضة ومعارك عالية
الكفاءة خلال فترة الإقامة في
كان التكوين من
أكمل قارب معقل أكثر من 40 قتالية
في الخدمة
كجزء من مجموعة الضربة البحرية للأسطول
أكثر من 80 صاروخا ومدفعية
اطلاق الرصاص
تمثل البحرية الروسية
السويد وفنلندا قبلها
قطعت السفينة أكثر من 15000 ميل
[موسيقى]
يواصل تشكيل سفن الصواريخ الصغيرة
قيادة صاروخ سفينة السخان
قبطان سفينة من الرتبة الثالثة فلاديمير
كوزلتسي
هل دخل هذا المشروع في البحرية
اسم الذبابة هو جلطة من المواد القتالية
إزاحة 700 طن حتى
بالعين المجردة يمكنك أن ترى كيف
السفينة مجهزة بالأسلحة والقتال
أنظمة
على متن هذا صغير نسبيا
سفينة
6 قاذفات مضادة للسفن
صاروخ كروز صاروخ مالاكيت مضاد للطائرات
وأسلحة المدفعية على مر السنين
خدمة السخان سفينة الصواريخ الصغيرة
شارك في 35 رحلة تجميع
اكتمال سفن أسطول البلطيق
أكثر من 60 مهمة قتالية
تتكون من مجموعة صدمة محمولة على متن السفن
من أسطول البلطيق بنجاح
مهام إطلاق الصواريخ والمدفعية
كل سفن الصواريخ الصغيرة من هؤلاء
أعطيت المشاريع أسماء الطقس
تقليديا
سفن دورية تيك العظيمة
جائزة الحرب الوطنية ضباب الرياح الموسمية
هذا هو السبب وراء الأسطول وراءهم
تم تحديد اسم التقسيم السيئ
الجو
دور علوي للبحرية السوفيتية
اتحاد الأدميرال الأواني
أطلقوا على هذه السفن مسدسًا في المعبد
الإمبريالية
يكمل مرور أحدث صغير
سفينة الصواريخ Serpukhov التي
يمثل جيلًا جديدًا من الصواريخ
سفن البحرية
بنيت في Zelenodolsk
قائد أحواض بناء السفن
قائد سفينة ملازم
يحتاج بيتر إلى سفينة مجهزة بمجمع
أسلحة الصواريخ الموجهة بدقة
قاذفات عمودية
عيار
السماح بضرب المجنح
الصواريخ
لكل من الأهداف البحرية والبرية
نظام الصواريخ المضادة للطائرات و
وضع المدفعية متر
تثبيت
السمة المميزة لهذه السفن
هو طلاء حالة خاصة و
تصميم خاص لطائرة خياله
مما يقلل بشكل كبير من الاحتمال أ
سفينة الكشف عن العلامة التجارية في البحر في
ديسمبر 2015 ، تم تسجيل السفينة
تكوين البحرية وبالفعل من
مارس إلى يوليو 2016 أداء المهام
الخدمة القتالية في الجزء الشرقي
شارك البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​في
عملية عسكرية عربية سورية
الجمهوريات في وقت قصير
السفن الخضراء دول و serpukhov
جعل الانتقال بين الجسد من
بحر البلطيق المتوسط ​​و
تقدم حاليا
حرمة البحرية الغربية
حدود روسيا
طاقم السفينة على استعداد للوفاء بأي
مهام رونين و
[موسيقى]
على الشاشات
مدينة المجد العسكرية كرونشتاد
[موسيقى]
خلال العرض البحري الرئيسي
السفن التي ، في إزاحتها الخاصة
وهطول الأمطار لا يمكن أن يدخل فإنه سوف يمر
هنا عن طريق قناة الشحن البحري
سان بطرسبرج
هنا على بحر كرونستادت
راندي
عقد الشاب القيصر بيتر العرض الأول
قوات الأسطول الروسي
بمناسبة الذكرى الثانية لنيشتات
السلام من الرصيف إلى كرونشتاد
غادرت أسراب الأدميرال إلى سبيريدوف و
الأزرق لجلب الشهرة
أسطول البحر الأسود
من هنا ذهب سرب الأدميرال إلى النسيان
عيد الميلاد
تم تجهيز المشاهير هنا
بعثات بحثية لازاريف و
bellingshausen و kruzenshtern و
ليسيانسكي
كرونشتاد هي مهد الأسطول الروسي
إحياء القلب والمركز الروحي
كاتدرائية كرونستادت البحرية ومرة ​​أخرى
فتحت البوابات للصلاة من أجل الأسطول
لدعم أداء البحارة لدينا
المهام بعيدًا عن الشواطئ المحلية
الكنسي من العرض البحري الرئيسي
أحضرت الكاتدرائية رفات القديس
المحارب الصالح فيودور أوشاكوف
أميرال الأسطول الروسي الذي لا يعرف
الهزائم
الجبهة المضادة للغواصات
مجموعة تكتيكية صغيرة
السفن المضادة للغواصات Kazanets و
زيلينودولسك كبير مضاد للغواصات
سفينة
نائب الأدميرال في القيادة
قائد مجموعة تكتيكية من الدرجة الأولى
أندري كليمينكو السفن في الدرجة الأولى
مصممة للبحث عن التتبع و
تدمير الغواصات
بشكل مستقل وكجزء من السفينة
البحث عن دعم مجموعة الإضراب
الدفاع ضد الغواصات للسفن
مغادرة القاعدة وعند معبر البحر
صد هجمات القوات الجوية والسطحية
العدو اليوم هذه السفن
تقديم اختبار لأحدث التصاميم
الأسلحة والمعدات العسكرية ل
أفراد البحرية
السفن
يحسن التدريب البحري و
مهنيا
رؤى في التعلم المسطح المشترك
[موسيقى]
نعم ، شارع كرونشتاد كبير
سفينة مضادة للغواصات
نائب الأدميرال بقبضة كبيرة
مشروع 1155 السفن المضادة للغواصات
تشكل أساس القوات المضادة للغواصات
البحرية وقادرة
تعمل في البحر البعيد
ومناطق المحيطات على جميع سفن هؤلاء
ستكون المشاريع عميقة
تحديث أنظمة الحظر
أجهزة دعم الحياة والإلكترونية
كشف
سفن مماثلة حاليا
شن القتال
مياه المحيط الهادئ والهند و
المحيط الأطلسي في عام 2016
طاقم سفينة كبيرة مضادة للغواصات
قام نائب الأدميرال بقبضة اليد المهام
الخدمة العسكرية على طول طريق الشمال
طريق البحر
ثم كجزء من حاملة طائرات محمولة على متن السفن
مجموعات الاسطول الشمالي للجزء الشرقي
شارك البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​في الجيش
عمليات الجمهورية العربية السورية
اجتياز 12 ألف ميل بحري في يونيو 2017
عام انتقل إلى أسطول بحر البلطيق ل
المشاركة في العرض البحري الرئيسي
طاقم السفينة محترف
البحارة المدربين
يستحق المجد خلفاء و
التقاليد البطولية للبحارة الشماليين
موكب اسطول المجموعة التكتيكية
السفن الضاربة كجزء من الأحدث
فرقاطات أميرال أسطول شمال الاتحاد السوفيتي
اتحاد الأواني والحراس كورفيت
أوامر تكتيكية ذكية
مجموعات
الكابتن أليكسي سوغروبوف المرتبة الأولى
السفن مسلحة
أنظمة الصواريخ الدقيقة
العيار وحولهم مع إمكانية الهزيمة
الأهداف البحرية والساحلية
مجهزة بصواريخ مضادة للطائرات ومجمعات
بوليمنت معقل قوي
المدفعية وطوربيد الألغام
أسلحة أحدث مشروع فرقاطة 22
350 أميرال أسطول الاتحاد السوفيتي
الأواني
بنيت في حوض بناء السفن
حوض بناء السفن الشمالي سانت بطرسبرغ
أول سفينة المحيط
مصممة ومصممة ل
البحرية الروسية
صناعة الأواني أميرال الفرقاطة
الأكثر تعقيدًا على الإطلاق
السفن الحديثة
السفينة مجهزة بأحدث
أنواع الأسلحة
الذي سابقا
لا تستخدم أثناء بنائه
تم استخدام أكثر من 30 في المئة
في احسن الاحوال
تقنيات ومواد فريدة
دائرة دفاع السفينة قادرة على
التقاط ومرافقة ما يصل في وقت واحد
16 جسمًا طائرًا والذي يتم دمجه مع
بندقية آلية عيار 130
ملليمترات والنظام الآلي
التوجيه وكذلك نظام قوي
يجعل هذا التشويش الإلكتروني
السفينة غير معرضة للخطر عمليا القادمة
ألوية ستصبح جزءًا من الشمال
الأسطول المشرف حق المشاركة بشكل رئيسي
موكب بحري
عهد إلى بحارة المظليين في بحر البلطيق
موكب اسطول المجموعة التكتيكية
سفن الإنزال
كجزء من سفينة إنزال كبيرة
الكسندر شبالين و الاحدث الكبير
أوامر سفينة الإنزال إيفان جرين
مجموعة
كابتن إسكندر المرتبة الثالثة
حفيف
[موسيقى]
سفينة هبوط كبيرة الكسندر
شبالين يمثل مشاة البحرية
سميت السفينة على اسم بطل مرتين
السوفياتي
الأدميرال ألكسندر أوسيبوفيتش
شبالين خلال الحرب الوطنية العظمى
الحروب
الكسندر Osipovich القيادة والطوربيد
أعطى القارب 32 قتال
سفينة ونقل العدو مثل
لم تكن هناك إنجازات أقل
طاقم سفينة إنزال كبير
الكسندر شبالين
فاز بالجائزة 10 مرات
القائد العام للقوات البحرية
تدريب الهبوط الكبير
سفينة
يمثل إيفان جرين جيلًا جديدًا
سفن الإنزال الروسية 2
إنزال هذه السلسلة بيتر
تم وضع Morgunov العام الماضي
أعلى حوض بناء السفن العنبر
سفن هذه المشاريع قادرة
توفير وسائل النقل والنزول
اعتداء برمائي أتصرف على مسافة بعيدة و
بالقرب من المناطق البحرية وكذلك
إجراء انتقالات داخلية
الممرات المائية
كبير هنا
لدى إيفان جرين ما يكفي للشحن
للدفاع عن النفس ودعم الهبوط
الصواريخ والمدفعية
حظيرة تتسع لشخصين
هليكوبتر ka-29
أو يمكن لسفينة واحدة من طراز ka-52 أن تأخذها
على متن ما يصل إلى 380 من مشاة البحرية و
36 وحدة من مختلف المركبات المدرعة
الوقت الحاضر
مكاتب التصميم في بلدنا
تطوير هبوط واعد جديد
سفن البحرية
حسب خصائصه وقدراته
سوف يتجاوزون كل ما هو موجود
نظائرها الأجنبية
[موسيقى]
تنص مجموعة تيغران على مجموعة تكتيكية
غواصات
كبير
غواصات كهربائية زيلي
فلاديكافكاز فيليكي نوفغورود
واحد كقائد لمجموعة تكتيكية
كابتن من المرتبة الثانية وزرعك
الغواصات من جميع الأجيال دائمًا
تتميز بمهنية عالية و
شجاعة
الحب والتفاني
الوطن في سنوات الوطنية العظمى
الحروب
صنع الغواصات أكثر من 1200 قتال
حملات نتيجة أنشطتها القتالية
في غرق أكثر من 100 سفينة حربية و
300 عملية نقل للعدو بشكل عام
الضغط
أكثر من مليون طن
والأسطول العظيم تحت الماء للاتحاد السوفيتي
التحالف خلال الحرب الباردة
كتب مكتوبة
الأفلام والبرامج التلفزيونية
يكفي أن نتذكر ذلك في عام 1965
تمرين للأسطول الشمالي
نشرت 48 غواصة
مناورات المحيط 77 خرجت تسعة وخمسون
وحدات على تمارين المحيط 80 في المحيط الأطلسي
أكثر من 50 غواصة تعمل في
بما في ذلك 21 غواصة صاروخية
استراتيجية لنا
في نفس الوقت الذي تكمل فيه المهام
العين العليا
طويلة الأمد وقيادة ماهرة للأسطول
الفترة من 1965 إلى 1985
لقب بطل الاتحاد السوفيتي وبطل
العمل الاشتراكي
منحت أكثر من 50 أميرالاً وضابطاً
الغواصات
نحن ممتنون للغاية لهم شيوخنا
زميل مرشد ومعلم
أساس القوة البحرية للدولة
تحولت وضعت من أيديهم هكذا
بحزم أنه حتى اليوم قواتنا الغواصة
واحدة من أقوى وأقوى الجاهزين للقتال في
عالم للأداء المثالي
القيادة العليا والماهرة
إدارة الأسطول
الفترة من 1965 إلى 1985 لقب البطل
الاتحاد السوفياتي والبطل
العمل الاشتراكي
وأكثر من 50 أميرالاً
وضباط الغواصات الحديثة
أسطول الغواصات هو تجسيد للمتقدم
فكر بناء السفن الثوري
أفكار للإبداع
وتشغيل المركبات تحت الماء
صفات قتالية عالية من الديزل لدينا
غواصات
سمح لهم بتنفيذ القتال بشكل فعال
الخدمات
نجحت في التغلب على الغواصات المضادة
حدود وتنفيذ طويلة
النزول خلف الغواصات
العدو المحتمل في هذا الاتجاه
مكان خاص ينتمي إلى الديزل
غواصات كهربائية
الجيل الرابع
مشروع 636 و 677
بكفاءة منخفضة الضوضاء
المدى الطويل والمدة
ملاحة مسلحة بالحديثة
أنظمة الصواريخ وطوربيدات
واعدة
هندسة الراديو والملاحة
أنظمة روبليف هذه السنوات القادمة
تشكل الأساس
القوى الذكية في بحر البلطيق والبحر الأسود
أساطيل
[موسيقى]
الغواصات الحديثة
من أسطول البحر الأسود فيليكي نوفغورود و
اشترى لديك أحدث طوربيد
التسلح
ونظام الصواريخ عيار على
هجوم صاروخي كرونستاد على الطراد
المارشال أوستينوف في قيادة السفينة
كابتن الرتبة الأولى سيرجي أولادييف
طرادات الصواريخ لهذه المشاريع
مصممة للضرب
على متن السفينة
لمن ولرؤوس أموال العدو
لضمان الاستقرار القتالي
مجموعات الضربة المنخفضة المضادة للغواصات
السفن وكذلك عند أداء المهام
تشكيلات الدفاع الجوي و
قوافل را عن بعد
حالة الطوارئ في العالم بتوقيت المحيط
الطبخ الطراد
الارتفاع 12 دقيقة فقط
صلاحية السفينة للإبحار لا يحدها أي شيء
التسلح الرئيسي للطراد هو
إضراب نظام سلاح الصواريخ و 500
ذهب طراد البازلت عميقًا
تحديث أنظمة الأسلحة
وسائل هندسة الراديو ووسائل الاتصال
عند علامة النجمة الخاصة بحوض بناء السفن في
مدينة سيفيرودفينسك
أمامنا سفينة جديدة تمامًا
بصاروخ حديث
المدفعية وهي طوربيد
أسلحة لأول مرة في التاريخ
خط موكب أسطول البلطيق
سفن البحرية
جيش التحرير الشعبي الصيني
وصلت سفن الجمهورية الشعبية في
والتي من خلال إطار بحر البلطيق
تدريبات بحرية ثنائية
تفاعل 2017 السفن كان عليها
تمر عبر محيطين 6 بحار
خريف المضائق والخلجان والسويس
تدريب القناة 1
مع النجاح في النهاية استغرقت المناورات
مشاركة 20 سفينة وطائرة في
في المرحلة التالية من الدول الجامدة
من العمل مع
في مياه بحر أوخوتسك وبحر اليابان
[موسيقى]
كيف
التي اعتمدتها البحرية
الصين 2015 سفينة لديها 100
30 ملم مدفعية
تثبيت
نظام صاروخي قادر على الضرب
هواء
السطح وكذلك الأجسام الأرضية و
تضم سفينتك 280 شخصًا
إزاحة سبعة آلاف ونصف مجلد
سرعة تصل إلى 30 عقدة
يواصل العرض
تكليف الفرقاطة yuncheng السفينة
الأسطول الجنوبي للشعب الصيني
جمهورية عام 2010 طاقم السفينة
مرارا وتكرارا لمسافات طويلة البحر
رحلات زار البلدان
حوض البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​وكذلك في
المملكة المتحدة وفرنسا
إزاحة السفينة 3600 طن
سرعة 27 عقدة للطاقم 165
رجل يقود سفينة
العميد الخلفي وأولمارت من الخلف
[موسيقى]
لأول مرة في التاريخ الوطني خلال
العرض البحري الرئيسي
بحر البلطيق الأكبر في العالم
طرادات الصواريخ النووية الثقيلة للنظام
صاروخ ناخيموف النووي الثقيل
الطراد بيتر الأكبر أقوى و
السفينة المحمية في القائد العالمي
قبطان سفينة الرتبة الأولى فلاديسلاف
تمتلك سفينة مالاخوف القدرة
ضرب البحر الكبير
الطراد يحمل أهدافًا تحت الماء وعلى السطح
على متن الطائرة بعد ذلك
بعد كل شيء ، قاذفات عالية الدقة
صواريخ كروز الجرانيت قادرة على الضرب
أهداف تصل إلى 550 كيلومترًا
أنظمة مضادة للطائرات s-300 on
صاروخ قوي مثبت على متن الطائرة
المدفعية وطوربيد الألغام
التسلح هناك نوعان من الغواصات المضادة
هليكوبتر ka-27
كل هذه الأسلحة مجتمعة
وسائل فريدة للكشف و
تتبع الهدف
محطة طاقة نووية قوية
السماح لتقديم غير محدود
العثور على سفينة في البحر
جعل الطراد البحر منيعة
قلعة ثقيلة على الشاشات الذرية
غواصة الصواريخ
الغرض الاستراتيجي
ديمتري دونسكوي
قبطان سفينة من الدرجة الأولى
مشروع oleg tsybin 941 الاعصار
صممه مكتب التصميم
في سان بطرسبرج
تفوق السفينة
جميع نظائرها الأجنبية مجهزة بصاروخ
مجمع بالصواريخ الباليستية
لديه طوربيد
الأجهزة مع طوربيدات وطوربيدات صاروخية
تصل سرعة السفر تحت الماء إلى 25
عقدة و عمق غمر يصل إلى 500 متر
انها الوحيدة
سفينة عالمية قادرة على تحمل القتال
واجب في القطب الشمالي جسده
قادرة على كسارة تصل إلى 2
[موسيقى]
ومرة أخرى في سانت بطرسبرغ حيث في هذه الدقائق
يبدأ قسم الهواء
عرض بحري في السماء أعلاه
مدينة أفضل سفينة في العالم
طائرات الهليكوبتر ka-52 لآلات katran قادرة على
ضرب المركبات المدرعة
القوة البشرية للعدو والأهداف الجوية
زعيم لمسافات طويلة
تكريم طيار الاختبار
Oleg Krivoshein أواصل العرض
طائرات هليكوبتر هجومية من طراز Mi-24 رائدة
أغلقت مجموعة المقدم ألكسندر أكثر
ساحة مجلس الشيوخ
نقل طائرات الهليكوبتر القتالية إلى 29
قائد المجموعة المقدم يوري كولتسوف
توفر هذه الآلات النزول بشكل موثوق
هجوم برمائي وغطاء نيرانه
في السماء مجموعة من طائرات الهليكوبتر المضادة للغواصات
على متن السفن حتى 27
قائد المجموعة المقدم أوليغ
مروحيات تكاتشينكو من هذه التعديلات
أظهرت فعاليتها في
كشف غواصات العدو
إدخال الاستطلاع البحري والتنفيذ
ومرة أخرى اكتملت عمليات الإنقاذ
عرض نقل تكنولوجيا طائرات الهليكوبتر على
طائرات هليكوبتر قتالية من طراز Mi-8
قائد المجموعة الرائد يفغيني داوتوف و 8
الأكثر موثوقية وبسيط و
هليكوبتر منتجة بكميات كبيرة لكامل
تاريخ صناعة طائرات الهليكوبتر
الطيارين في السماء فوق سانت بطرسبرغ
الطيران البحري لأسطول البحر الأسود
ورثة المجد العسكري والتقاليد 318
راية حمراء مختلطة منفصلة
كونستانس قائد فوج الطيران
مجموعات من الطائرات المضادة للغواصات be-12
طيار من الدرجة الأولى مقدم
فاسيلي جوملسكي خلال العملية
هذه الآلات المجنحة الفريدة
وضع 46 رقما قياسيا عالميا في السماء
الطائرات من طراز An-140 التي تم تصميمها للطائرة
للنقل والركاب
النقل في مناخات مختلفة
يمكن استخدام الشروط على
مع المطارات القصيرة و
قائد عصابات غير مهيأة
رائد الطاقم
أليكسي بارسوكوف
[موسيقى]
طائرات نقل عسكرية تمر
اللفتنانت كولونيل يوري AN-72
أحواض
لا غنى عن الطائرات للتسليم
الأسلحة والمعدات العسكرية في
المناطق التي يصعب الوصول إليها في القطب الشمالي
قادرة على الإقلاع والهبوط
الأرض مغطاة بالثلوج أو جديدة
المطارات في السماء فوق سانت بطرسبرغ
أساطير الطيران البحري المضاد للغواصات
طائرات IL-38 ومواصلة الهواء
جزء من المسيرة واحدة من أكبر و
طائرات الدفع التوربيني عالية السرعة
الطائرات العالمية والمضادة للغواصات بعيدة المدى
الكشف عن Tu-142 عضو الكنيست
طائرة IL-78 في السماء
تم عرض إعادة تزويد الطائرات بالوقود من طراز Tu-142
في الهواء
قيادة المجموعة العقيد إيغور حشد هكتار
[موسيقى]
الطيارون يواصلون العرض الجوي 43
طلب لافتة حمراء سيفاستوبول
فوج الطيران الهجومية كوتوزوف
من أسطول البحر الأسود من بين الأفضل في العالم
متعددة الوظائف فائقة المناورة
Su-30cm جيل 4 + +
قائد المجموعة المقدم أندريه كوجوت
[موسيقى]
مقاتلات Su-33279 في السماء
مقاتلة سفينة
سمولينسك للطيران
عصا الراية الحمراء للأسطول الشمالي
سميت على اسم بطل الاتحاد السوفياتي مرتين
بوريس سافونوف
قائد المجموعة العقيد بافيل تحت الجثة
في السماء
مقاتلات طيران بحري من طراز Su-27
قائد المجموعة المقاتلة المقدم
جسور فلاديمير
خلال الوجود
الفطائر 8 أرقام قياسية عالمية
معدلات الصعود المتبقية
لا نظير لهما
وحاليا موكب
أفضل طقس في العالم
مقاتلات اعتراضية من طراز MiG-31 تقود
أزواج من مجموعتي الرومانية ترونوف الرئيسية المكونة من 4
الطائرات
يمكن للمرء على الأقل التحكم في الهواء
مساحة تصل إلى ألف
كيلومترات ببساطة
[موسيقى]
مشترك في عملية المسح المتغير
جناح جناح su-24m زعيم المجموعة
المقدم لي مؤامرات القتال
كفاءة وموثوقية هذه
أكد نجاح الطائرات علينا
خلفية العملية العسكرية في سوريا
الجمهورية العربية
موكب تشكيل الطيران البحري
القوات البحرية
المقاتلين القائم على الناقل
الخيط إلى الفريق الرائد مقدم
الرماة سيرجي خوذات مجنحة جدا
الآلات و
الطيارون القائمون على الناقل في الأسطول الشمالي
طائرات من هذا النوع
يفوق أي من دوله الغربية
المشجعين
[موسيقى]
استكمال استعراض الطيران البحري
6 طائرات Su-25
هم يهزون السماء من فوق
سان بطرسبرج
الروسية داخل اللون قبالة
[موسيقى]
أنت في نهاية اليوم البحري
تحية المدفعية البحرية البحرية
على شاشات الفيديو للبنادق المطلقة
طراد الصواريخ النووية الثقيلة
بيتر العظيم
وابل من جثث التحية الموجودة على
ميناء وهياكل الحماية في كرونشتاد
لعبة التحية عند الوقوف على الغارة أليس كذلك
يكمل المدفعية الاحتفالية
التحية
تحية البطارية في بتروبافلوفسك
القلاع
[موسيقى]
موسيقى العرض العسكري الرئيسي في أومسك
ينفذ
فرقة عسكرية
لوتو في تكوينه مركزي
الفرقة المثالية للبحرية
أوركسترا الأميرالية لينينغراد
عصابات القاعدة البحرية
مؤسسات التدريب البحري
سان بطرسبرج
موصل تكريم فنان روسيا
المرتبة الأولى أليكسي جينوفا
لكننا محميين
[موسيقى]
لكن
أنت
و
[موسيقى]
أجزاء من روسيا
و
[موسيقى]
أنا
موغيليف
[موسيقى]
استمع إلى البحر والسماء الزرقاء
لنا
هنا
الإخراج والجيش
تؤديها الأوركسترا الأصلية
بدا البحرية
قطعة موسيقية
فنان الشعب مؤلف الجيش والبحرية
اللفتنانت جنرال الروسي فاليري خليلوف
أكمل الأخ القائد البحري